Nous allons parler de mon -- un nouvel exposé, créé juste
pour TED -- et je vais vous montrer quelques illusions
que nous avons créés pour TED, et je vais essayer
de relier cela au bonheur. Ce que je pensais
a propos du bonheur, ce qui donne du bonheur ou --
bonheur, que j'assimile à la joie dans mon
domaine particulier, et je pense qu'il y a quelque chose de très
fondamental. Et je pensais à ça. Et
c'est à la fois en termes d'illusions et des films que nous
allons voir et des blagues et des spectacles de magie, et qu'il y a
quelque chose dans tout cela où nos
attentes sont violés d'une sorte de manière
plaisante. Vous allez voir un film. Et il a un retournement
surprenant-- quelque chose que vous n'attendiez pas -- et
vous y trouvez une expérience joyeuse. Vous regardez toutes ces
sortes d'illusions dans mon livre, et ce n'est pas ce à quoi
vous vous attendiez. Et il y a quelque chose de plaisant,
là-dedans. Et c'est la même chose avec les blagues, et
tous les trucs dans ce genre. Donc ce que je vais essayer
de faire dans cet exposé, c'est d'aller plus loin
et de voir si je peux prendre votre bon sens en défaut
de manière plaisante. Parfois, les attentes qui sont
violées ne sont pas agréables, mais je vais tenter
de le faire d'une manière plaisante, d'une manière très primaire
afin que je puisse rendre ce public heureux.
Donc, je vais vous montrer quelques manières de tromper
vos attentes. Premièrement, je voudrais vous
montrer cette illusion-là. Je voudrais que vous
remarquiez, lorsqu'il s'affichera à l'écran que
les deux trous sont perpendiculaires l'un à
l'autre. C'est tous des trucage perceptuels. Ce sont
des objets réels, que je vous montre. Maintenant
je vais vous montrer comment c'est fait. J'ai mis
le film en boucle, là, pour vous faire vivre une expérience
très intéressante. Vous voyez comment l'illusion est
construite, et l'objet va tourner pour que vous voyiez
qu'il est construit a l'envers. Maintenant, regardez-le alors qu'il tourne
a quel vitesse votre perception change. Ok maintenant.
L'objet revient en arrière. Et c'est une audience particulièrement
intelligente, vrai ? Essayez d'empecher de changer
de sens, même si vous êtes 100% sûr que c'est une
illusion -- Bam! Impossible de l'empêcher. Qu'est ce que
cela vous apprend sur vous ? On le refait
Aucun doute sur l'objet. Essayez de l'empêcher
de changer. Non, C'est difficile.
Et nous pouvons tromper vos attentes de mille et une
façons, en jouant sur la représentation, sur la forme,
sur la couleur, etc, c'est particulièrement primaire.
Une question intéressante à se poser. Pourquoi ces
trucs -- on les trouve amusants. Pourquoi devrions
nous les trouver amusant ?
Voici quelque chose que Lionel a fait il y a pas mal de temps.
J'aime beaucoup ce genre de petite truc, comme ça.
Une fois de plus, pas de trucage optique, c'est ce que
vous verriez. En d'autres termes, ce n'est pas un montage vidéo
C'est une astuce visuelle.
OK. On peut tromper votre oeil sur
la forme de l'objet.
On peut tromper votre oeil sur la représentation
-- Ce qu'une image représente. Que voyez vous là ?
Combien d'entre vous voit des dauphins ? Levez votre main
si vous voyez des dauphins. OK, ceux qui ont levé
leur main, après l'exposé, le reste de l'audience,
allez leur parler, ok ? En fait, c'est le
meilleur exemple d'illusion par l'expérience que je connaisse.
Si vous êtes un enfant de moins de 10 ans, qui
n'a pas déjà été gaché, vous regarderiez cette
image et verriez des dauphins. Maintenant, certains d'entre vous, adultes
se disent : "Quels dauphins ? quels dauphins ?"
Mais de fait, si vous renversez les couleurs de la figure --
autrement dit, les aires sombres ici -- j'ai oublié de
demander un pointeur -- mais si vous les renversez, vous verrez
toute une série de petits dauphins. Au passage,
si vous êtes un étudiant à CalTech -- Ils ont aussi
tendance à ne voir que les dauphins. C'est basé sur
l'expérience.
Quelque chose comme ca peut être utilisé parce que,
après tout, nous parlons aussi de design. Donc, cela a été
utilisé par Saatchi and Saatchi, et ils ont sorti
cette publicité en Australie. Si vous regardez
cette publicité pour de la bière, toutes ces personnes sont dans des
positions très provocantes. Mais ils l'ont passé, et
ont même gagné les Clio Awards, c'est donc amusant de faire
ce genre de choses.
Vous vous souvenez de ce ... Voici une blague que j'ai faite
lorsque l'on parlait du ballot de loi, en Floride. Vous
savez, comptez les points pour Gore, comptez les points
pour Bush. Recomptez-les.
Nous pouvons tromper vos attentes sur votre
expérience. Voici une fontaine extérieure que
J'ai construite avec quelques amis, où vous pouvez
arrêter les gouttes d'eau et faire leviter
toutes les gouttes. On construit cela
pour les parcs d'attractions
et les trucs dans le genre.
Maintenant, prenons une image statique. Pouvez vous voir ca ?
Est ce que vous voyez la section du milieu descendre, et les
sections extérieures monter ? C'est complètement fixe.
C'est une image fixe. Combien de personnes voient cette
Illusion? C'est complètement fixe.
Bon, maintenant -- c'est intéressant de constater que lorsque
nous regardons une image, nous voyons la couleur, la profondeur,
la texture. Et vous pouvez regardez cette scène et
l'analyser. Vous pouvez voir la femme plus proche que
le mur, etc. Mais le tout est en fait
plat. C'est un tableau. Un trompe l'oeil.
Et c'est un tellement bon trompe-l'oeil que les gens
s'énervait quand ils essayait de parler
à la femme et qu'elle ne répondait pas.
Vous pouvez aussi faire des erreurs de conception. Comme celui-là
un bâtiment dans New York. Quand vous le regardez de
ce coté, il semble que les balcons penchent vers le haut
et quand vous marchez jusqu'à l'autre coté, ils
semblent pencher vers le bas. Donc il y a des
cas où des erreurs de conception dans le design conduisent
à creer des illusions.
Ou, vous pouvez prendre cette image particulière,
non-retouchée. C'est intéressant car je reçois beaucoup
de courriels de personnes me demandant "y-a-t-il des
différences de perception entre hommes et femmes ? "
Et je réponds "Non". Les femmes peuvent naviguer
dans notre monde de la même manière que les hommes -- et
pourquoi ne pourraient-elles pas ? Cependant, pour cette illusion
précise, les femmes sont systématiquement meilleures
que les hommes : elles accordent la tête à la bonne personne
en se basant sur le style vestimentaire. Elles font concorder le chapeau au reste.
Maintenant -- J'aimerais vous montrer
du design dans les illusions. Je crois que les premiers
exemples d'illusions créés pour l'illusion le furent par
de Vinci, dans son image anamorphique de l'oeil. De telle manière que
vous devez regarder l'image avec un petit angle comme ca.
Et cette technique fut assez populaire au cours
du 16ème et 17ème siècle pour maquiller
des sens cachés, ou vous pouviez renverser l'image, et
la voir d'un point de vue serré comme ça.
Mais ces premières incorporations d'illusions,
arrivèrent à un genre d'apogée avec "Les Ambassadeurs"
de Hans Holbein. Hans Holbein travaillait pour
Henry VIII. Le tableau était suspendu à un mur dans
un escalier, et lorsque vous descendiez l'escalier, vous pouviez voir
ce squelette caché.
Bon, maintenant je vais vous montrer quelques
travaux de designers, qui utilisent les illusions pour creer
cet élément de surprise. L'un de mes favoris est Scott
Kim. J'ai travaillé avec lui pour créer quelques illusions
pour TED, j'espère que vous les apprécierez. Celle-là
est sur TED et le bonheur.
Ok. Arthur [Ganson] n'a pas encore fait sa présentation, mais elle
va être extraordinaire, et il a quelques unes de ses
machines fantastiques exposées dehors. Donc nous
-- Scott a créé ce magnifique tribut à Arthur
Ganson.
Bon, il y a Analogue et Digital. J'ai pensé que c'était
appropriée dans ce cas.
et "figure" se transforme en "ground"
Et pour les musiciens.
Et bien sur, puisque le bonheur -- nous voulons la "joie dans
le monde"
Maintenant, un autre excellent designer -- très connu
connu au Japon -- Shigeo Fukuda. Et il a construit
des choses fantastiques. Ceci est juste
incroyable. Voici un tas d'ordure, et quand vous le regardez
d'un angle particulier, vous pouvez voir
sa reflexion dans le miroir, comme un piano parfait.
Un pianiste se transforme en violoniste.
Un truc très sauvage. Un assemblage de fourchette,
de couteau et de cuiller et d'autres couverts, assemblés
ensemble, donnent l'ombre d'une moto. Vous apprenez
quelque chose, quand vous faites mon genre de travail, qui est
qu'il y a des gens dans ce monde avec énormément
de temps à occuper.
Ken Knowlton fait des images composites magnifiques. Comme
faire Jacques Cousteau en coquillages --
des coquillages non retouché, juste en les arrangeant.
Il a fait Einstein à partir de dés, parce qu'après tout,
Einstein disait : "Dieu ne joue pas au dés avec
l'univers." Bert Herzog à partir de claviers
non-retouchés. Will Shortz, des mots croisés.
John Cederquist fait ces magnifique toilettes
trompe-l'oeil.
Je vais aller directement à la section suivante, je suis en retard.
J'aimerais vous montrer rapidement ce que j'ai créé.
Quelques illusions d'un nouveau type. J'ai fait
quelque chose en prenant des illusions de type Pixar. Donc
vous voyez ces enfants ont la même taille, là. En courant
dans le hall. Les tables font la même taille.
Ils regardent dans deux directions différentes en même temps.
Vous avez une pièce plus grande dans une plus petite.
Et ce quelquechose auquel vous pouvez réfléchir, d'accord ?
Vous voyez cette plus grosse pièce tenir dans
la plus petite. Tout le monde le voit ? C'est bien sûr
impossible. Vous pouvez voir les deux enfants
regardant dans deux directions différents simultanément.
Pouvez-vous croire que ces deux dessus de
tables ont même taille et même forme ?
Si vous les mesuriez, vous le verriez. Comme je l'ai dit
ces deux images sont identiques en taille et en forme.
C'est intéressant, en faisant ce genre de
rendu, à quel point les illusions sont renforcées
Dans tous les cas, J'espère que cela vous a apporté
une peu de joie et de bonheur, et si vous voulez
voir d'autres effets sympas, venez me voir
dehors, je serais ravi de vous montrer pleins de trucs.